well New York City's World Famous
Metropolitan Museum of Art is getting a
major facelift we are about to meet a
rising star of the architecture World
who's leading the half billion dollar
project Frida Escobedo the 43 year old
Mexican architect leaped over the
competition to redesign the Mets new
modern art Wing CBS News correspondent
Enrique Acevedo met Escobedo at the
Museum to talk about her work and what
it means to be the first woman and the
first Latina to design a wing of that
Institution
I was coming very often here and I
remember that this was completely
different Frida Escobedo is not looking
to compete for real estate in one of the
world's most famous skylines she's more
interested in building a sense of
belonging what do you see
um well I see a city that is composed of
many different cities and many different
communities and many different cultures
and that's why it's so fascinating about
New York the foundation Escobedo hopes
to build at the Mets latest Wing isn't
so much about the bricks as the mortar
that binds people together reserves like
these poetic elements about architecture
than we or all are fascinated with but
to me it's also about the personal
Journey how it makes it feel connected
to a larger thing whether it's a
community
or a city Escobedo who started her own
Architecture Firm in 2006 in Mexico City
has spent much of the last decade and
Beyond building and renovating Pavilions
museums and hotels all around the world
her designs are inventive provocative
and like New York City constantly
evolving is there a way to define your
style I don't like to think about styles
from much as a set of peroccupations
that we have but I feel like defining it
as a style can be a little bit dangerous
because then you start repeating what
you do and you stop experimenting and
you stop learning the med has a long and
storied history with Builders and
Architects most of them white men hiring
a young Mexico city-based architect like
Escobedo to be the first woman and the
first Latina ever to design a met Wing
is seen as a long overdue effort to be
more inclusive sometimes I get like
these mixed feelings about it because I
don't want to be perceived you know like
just like a token no one wants to do
that but at the same time I feel very
honored and lucky to have the
opportunity because I know this is a big
privilege I'm just thankful for all the
women that have opened the path for me
to be here
Escobedo is no stranger to New York City
for one of her most recent projects this
store in Brooklyn she brought brexit
from Mexico to match the color of Park
slope's Classic Homes a symbol of her
calling heart using space to connect
cultures
the Met project will be her biggest
undertaking yet it will create 80 000
square feet of Galleries and public
space for contemporary works that
include drawings photographs sculptures
and digital art pieces designing a
public building you don't have a
specific client even if you do because a
final user is someone who might come to
the museum to enjoy an afternoon and
then leave it might be a little girl
from Mexico exactly in New York for the
first time for the first time exactly
and when people Embrace that as a space
of their own then is when the magic
happens for Me Enrique Acevedo CBS News
New York
shout out to Frida Escobedo the first
but not the last